activism and protests are often part of
the fabric of university life but the
ramen golfing Oxford is bigger than this
campus it's about what many feel is
discrimination and even hate speech
versus an argument for free speech even
if it's divisive
Kathleen stock is a philosopher and was
a professor at the University of Sussex
until she quit after a backlash to her
so-called gender critical views namely
that trans women aren't women this
evening she addressed the Oxford Union
saying that trans women are not women is
the validating them it's a private room
of their identity I think it's
reasonable that people are
speaking and we can invite academic
guests to speak the question is and our
questions are asking whether there's
Merit some including the Prime Minister
came out in support of Stock's Oxford
appearance Rishi sunak is expected to
appoint a free speech star this week
it's a move against what's been called
cancel culture
today he found common ground with some
of his political opponents my message to
people who disagree with Kathleen stop
is don't try and cancel the debate go
along and take part in it
stocks talk was disrupted by this a
protester glued their hands to the floor
right in front of her causing police to
intervene no more dead trans kids read a
leaflet brought into the event
for the most part the demonstrators kept
to the streets the counter-protest was
Tiny in comparison but determined I
can't see how you could possibly be on
the right side of history when you're
demanding that others
deny the evidence of their own eyes in
order to affirm your identity that seems
to be an incredibly narcissistic and
dead-ended way of thinking and there are
many others who say they aren't
transphobic but have concerns for
instance about protecting Single Sex
spaces Reading university Professor Rosa
Friedman says she's feared for her
safety after speaking out
this is about time that the government
does step in and remind the country what
the laws are but also what the purpose
of universities are which is to produce
knowledge but also to tackle key
societal challenges in an expert and
evidence-based way can we just ask one
question how was that do you think that
the Prime Minister many trans people
feel that giving speakers like stock a
platform goes as far as to question
their very existence but there was a
large turnout for the event tonight the
debate around trans issues is often
described as toxic it's certainly raw
and can be emotional and it seems to be
getting even louder Becky Cottrell Sky
News Oxford